Ukrainian forces have repeatedly asked
the U.S for these they're the Army
tactical missile system attackums for
short these missiles can come equipped
with a 500 pound-class fragmentation
Warhead and have a maximum range of
about 190 miles which could allow
Ukrainian forces to reach further into
russian-held territories inside Ukraine
including Crimea in September U.S
officials said they would send a small
number of attackam's missiles to Ukraine
in coming weeks after debating the risk
of escalating tensions with Russia and
worrying about its small domestic
stockpile we've been supplying Ukraine
with items from our junk drawer as
opposed to the high-end missile
capabilities
here's how these missiles could speed up
Ukraine's counter-offensive against
Russia and why the U.S was initially
hesitant to send them
is the army field artillery's Premier
surface-to-surface strike system it
allows them to be mobile to disperse to
hide in terrain and clutter and to be
able to impose certain kinds of
uncertainty upon the enemy about where
they'll be coming from the attackums is
designed to be launched from a ground
vehicle like the U.S highmars which is
already in Ukraine once the missile is
fired
the ground vehicle can shoot and Scoot
to avoid retaliatory attacks this could
be a huge Advantage for Ukrainian forces
which have been using a similar missile
the UK's Storm Shadow that's fired from
an Airborne jet
it just offers one more level of
flexibility for the counter offense of
the other systems that require launching
by air limit where and when the
ukrainians can use them they need that
Air Platform this essentially empowers
Ground Forces to take these launchers
anywhere they need them one of the
interesting features of the hymar's
launcher is it doesn't reveal exactly
what what Bissell is carrying that's
advantageous because assuming an enemy
is surveilling you won't necessarily
know what's inside and won't know
whether it is a higher value a tackums
as opposed to the shorter range stuff
this gives ukrainians the added
advantage of firing missiles from
multiple types of domains including air
and ground but the heimer's mobility
means that ukrainians could get closer
to Russian territory further increasing
the missile's reach attackum's missiles
can reach up to 190 miles considerably
farther than the storm Shadows top range
of 155 miles there's just all kinds of
operational advantages to that greater
range that reach allows for instance
Ukrainian forces to be able to fire from
safer territory to not have to walk
right up to the Russian lines to be able
to hit something deeper back this
additional range could force Moscow to
move storage facilities and command
centers more than 200 miles from the
front and that could complicate efforts
to supply troops with food and
ammunition eating ukrainians and they're
counter-offensive plus this weapon could
be useful for getting a Ukrainian
targeting inside some of these Russian
Health territories for specifically
Crimea attackums can also move
significant
thickier than other missiles
or around 2 300 miles per hour in
contrast cruise missiles like the Storm
Shadow or Russia's kh-101 for example
have top speeds of only around 600 to
700 miles per hour the speed of the
atacums is simply a function of the fact
that it's a ballistic missile with the
big rocket engine single stage on the
back so this speed is useful for time
critical targets things that may move
that need to be hit very promptly the
attackum's guidance system combines
inertial navigation with GPS
this creates highly accurate targeting
preventing electronic jamming and
interference and minimizing collateral
damage on impact attackums are also
designed with features Adept at hitting
multiple types of targets these missiles
are highly maneuverable in the air
allowing them to hit targets from a
variety of angles simple ballistic
missile is going to travel on a
ballistic trajectory it's going to just
follow gravity's rainbow something
that's very predictable and curved the
benefit of maneuverability is that you
can interrupt that rainbow you can come
down in a different way you can maneuver
to be more On Target you can go after
perhaps a moving Target and correct for
for errors and yes you can come down
vertically if you'd like so that
vertical impact may be useful to come
right over top of targets and just make
it that much harder for it to see it
coming or to hit the vulnerable spot on
an armored vehicle attack Em's missiles
can contain one of two types of warheads
unitary or submunition a unitary warrant
is just what it sounds like it is one
big explosive it's in one piece
subunitions uh baumlets are likewise
what they sound like lots of little
things that spread out there's
advantages to both depending on what
you're targeting inside an attack em
subunition Warhead are hundreds of Steel
cased balls filled with incendiary
pellets which could be likened crudely
to a shotgun blast
where it has a large spray of explosive
impact on the Target and then there's a
unitary Warhead which would be crudely
like into a single bullet out of a
pistol
unitary Warheads are better at targeting
specific single targets while some
munition Warheads are highly effective
against moving personnel and Equipment
the unitary and the submunitions are
admittedly tailored for different things
but both of them can go after lots of
different targets so we don't know is
what variant they would provide or what
combination of variants they would
provide to the ukrainians despite
Ukraine's requests the U.S was hesitant
to send takims until now there was
concerns about escalating the conflict
with the Russians there's concerns that
the ukrainians could use these attackers
which have this long range and Target
inside Russian territory but we're also
at a point in the counter-offensive
which is it's gone a lot slower than
anybody expected and so the U.S may be
digging deeper into its pockets and
green lighting other Weapons Systems
that it didn't want to provide before
given kind of the time constraints the
Biden Administration faced increased
pressure from Ukraine and Congress to
send attackam's missiles last June
Congress signed a bipartisan resolution
in favor of sending attacks to Ukraine
and the Administration has reversed
course on weapons before like with the
Abrams tank but officials have also
expressed concern about the US's
domestic attack on stockpile U.S is
really trying to balance you know its
own National Security needs with those
of Ukraine and Europe at large and the
United States just doesn't have a whole
lot of these lying around they've been
out of production to some extent for
some time this recent reversal comes
shortly after a U.S army official said
that the replacement missile for the
attackums the prism will be out of
production and entering U.S stockpiles
in the near future the prism or
Precision strike missile can reach over
300 miles which is significantly farther
than the attackums that may also
mitigate some of the impact on the U.S
inventory to provide the attackers
that's kind of opening the door for
potentially providing them now